you know I've been thinking about
something 2022 it's been a weird year to
be a console gamer Acquisitions happen
left and right PlayStation exclusives
are starting to appear on PC Xbox
doubles down on cloud gaming and
Nintendo just continues to do its
Nintendo Thing by putting out solid ass
games but something else happened this
year which has had me questioning the
entire concept of what even makes a
video game console this thing
this was the year that the steam deck
rocked the world the PC and console
Gamers alike but before we can unpack
how that even happened let's start at
the beginning of 2022.
right out of the gate on January 18th
Microsoft Came Out Swinging with the
gargantuan plan to acquire Activision
Blizzard for 68.7 billion dollars which
now nearly a year later is still
undergoing scrutiny and approval out of
concern for its potential to monopolize
the market on the flip side Sony is
eating up its own share of developers
with the most prominent being the once
Microsoft owned studio Bungie but while
all this money is being spent and
companies are threatening each other
over who is monopolizing this or that or
who's getting exclusivity over what
I'm playing a PlayStation exclusive on a
handheld PC with an Xbox controller
back in February on the same day as the
release of Elden ring the steam deck
ship and started to trickle out into
people's hands I was admittedly very
skeptical of this thing at face value it
just was a big old piece of Hardware
with so many bells and whistles with its
dual track pads and back buttons and
when I actually managed to get one in my
hands for the first time I audibly
laughed and said holy [ __ ] at its weight
maybe I was just apprehensive because at
its core this is just a handheld PC and
as a console gamer I wasn't quite
convinced the steam deck would be able
to pull off that simple just boot up and
play approach that I expect with playing
games on consoles and really like that's
really about it I just was kind of
skeeved out of the idea of this just
being a PC while I was mostly raised as
a PC Gamer in my old age I've just
seemed to drift away from it because the
experience is not quite as fluid as it
is on a console and I'm also talking
about like the physical space in which
you play PC games that's important to me
incredibly important especially when it
pertains
to my desk
this is a sacred place
[Music]
it's why my desk is bare I want to have
the flexibility to just clear it all off
and work on something else to shift my
desk around while filming to not be
confined to a monitor a tower a keyboard
mouse speakers and all that jazz it is
why I've leaned into that no-nonsense
approach the boot up and play mentality
and speaking of comfort and flexibility
that is why I love
handhelds
it gives me the ability to play when I
want wherever I want I like to refer to
it as the treating games as books
mentality especially if you're playing
someone like Hotel dusk because it's
basically a book
you can carry a book around with you
read bits here and there between tasks
at night in the morning and so on in
fact I found that I am far more likely
to finish a game if I play this way
because gaming like this more adaptable
to my routine so with that in mind the
steam deck seems like the ideal thing
for me that is if it's stuck The Landing
obviously it did because you know
I probably would be making this video
after waiting for seven months I finally
got one and I was happy that also means
my cat Lily got a box to lamb that also
made me happy and because I am who I am
the first game I booted up just to see
if it work was D because what better
game to test on a big new piece of
Cutting Edge technology other than the
1995 FMB horror classic
Laura but really if there had been one
game I was hoping to finish with my old
games book method that I didn't get
around to on Console deaf stranding this
is a game ahead started when it released
in 2019 but it had Slipped Away into the
backlog and I knew if I could play it in
small doses either before going to bed
after breakfast or just a short break in
between chores I could potentially see
it through to the end and I did
when I did have some Sam Norman Porter
Rita's Bridges time to commit to I'd pop
it on my TV with an Xbox controller is
this the ideal way to experience a big
and beautiful AAA game
that's really up to what you as a player
value because it's graphical Fidelity
then
probably not but what it's given me is
the thing I love most
flexibility flexibility to experience
these games without having to hog up the
TV from my partner and on this screen on
this device it looked and played great
and after I was done with dust stranding
that's when it really sunk in just how
many games I never got around PC or
console ones that are now accessible
right here
it has created a scenario that has
allowed me to reap the benefits of both
PC and console gaming worlds oh and of
course a handheld one too in doing so
the whole Endeavor has suddenly had me
asking what even is a console anyway
at its core the steam deck is a PC a PC
with an emphasis on playing games it
delivers the console experience that
makes console gaming so approachable but
without compromising it as a personal
computer the difference is that out of
the box when you boot this up It's All
About Steam and its games boot up and
play so that makes us a console right
and if that is the case this is a
console that can play Xbox and
Playstation exclusives natively on
Playstation we're talking death
stranding Uncharted God of War Horizon
zero Dawn days gone Spider-Man Miles
Morales and stray they're all right
alongside Halo Forza gears 5 score and
immortality pentiment grounded meanwhile
the only console that actually has legit
exclusives anymore is the switch which
for the first time actually has a legit
competitor like so this one's still way
sexier I'm sorry it's just
look look at this no contest in the in
the in the saxophone in my opinion 2002
in general has been an interesting one
to unpack for consoles especially for
these sophomores one thing is apparent
exclusivity seems fickle games like sifu
came as a big win for the PS5 only to
come out on switch within the same year
additionally most of Sony's first party
games are now on Steam and death Loop is
now on Xbox on the other hand despite
Google stadia fizzling out this year
Xbox continues to support cloud gaming
putting an emphasis on making more and
more Game Pass games streamable to
nearly any device they even partnered
with Logitech for its Cloud only
handheld we also saw Sony finally take a
stab at their own version of Game Pass
rebranding its entire PS plus structure
and introducing the game catalog a
confusing competitor that features
several different tiers all of which
give players something different I've
learned about it on three separate
occasions and I'm still unsure off the
top of my head what tier gives you PS1
games with all that in mind I feel like
a broken record every single time I make
one of these videos but there has never
been more choices or possibilities for
us the gamers to decide how we want to
play our games and for someone like me
who is primarily a console gamer I'm now
playing once deemed PC only games on a
console
it's like a dream
[Music]
this all isn't to say I've had a totally
painless experience with a steam deck
some games take a little tinkering to
get running as smoothly as I prefer like
control there's also the battery in life
on more demanding games like dust
stranding which can leave a lot to be
desired still sitting with it plugged in
at certain times is a trade-off I was
willing to make then there's the case of
some older games like cold fear from
2005 which crashes before it even gets
to the menu screen woe is me
I know but then strangely games like
Tower unite which is marked unsupported
for the steam deck actually runs and
plays totally fine and it's moments like
these where I'm experimenting with what
works and what doesn't that I am
reminded it is at its core APC I don't
think console gaming is going anywhere
and I suspect we'll continue to see
generation after generation of Xboxes
and PlayStations but the steam deck has
added an interesting layer to the
concept of consoles
well Sony and Microsoft changed their
strategies if the steam deck takes off
in the mainstream zeitgeist
who knows time will tell nonetheless
it's a layer that enables me personally
to treat games as books to boot up and
play wherever I want when I want and in
doing so it is completely warped where I
decide to buy my games despite what
they're exclusive to
where's that vampire survivors come here
all right